[Music]
children poor little uh zionists were
walking and there's anti-Semitism it
doesn't work anymore you cannot CL
antisemitism why because the reality of
the matter is
what just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your that you read it wherever
you wasum guys so the IDF Israel Defense
Force whatever you want to call them for
that matter um some of the soldiers uh
and some Hans from Israel uh these uh as
you guys know we don't speak much about
them were're playing against a team in
the Netherlands they lost 5 new yes
they're losing everywhere uh in all
grounds they losing this battle this war
in all grounds with public opinion to
call it against resistance Etc now what
I'm about to show you I'm not condoning
any violence in any shape or form I'm
just showing you guys what's happened
I'm just you know I you can call me a
journalist for this matter you know uh
yeah so you know I condemn what's
happened uh on this matter you know as
you guys know you guys know my opinions
very clearly I seriously seriously
condemn what what happened yeah so let's
watch for ourself how it started because
the news were making this seem as if
that poor little uh zionists were
walking and there anti-Semitism it
doesn't work anymore you cannot CL
antisemitism why because the reality of
the matter is what actually happened so
the news articles that were coming out
and saying oh they got attacked Etc they
were just there for a football match no
they were not let's look at it step by
step of what they were chanting and
after that what that actually means cuz
the chant that they're seeing for
example let us idea finished the war so
we can f the Arabs here's the footage
you're going to see for yourself in I'm
going to dissect it step by step here's
the first
[Music]
footage now you know how it feel
sir say fre paltin and we
go good so what you saw there guys
brother and sisters was what them saying
let us uh finish IDF so we can f word
the Arabs yes then afterwards this chant
is a long chant which actually says um
that they have there are no schools
there are the schools are empty in Gaza
because all the children are basically
massacred as you can see for that matter
so that's where it is not only that as
you can see in the images as I'm going
to tell you you're going to be see the
images they went and start ripping off
Palestinian Flags step by step they will
keep doing this left right cender then
there's a footage of them trying to
attack a cab driver which you will see
the footage then after that after them
chanting
um as you can see not only
racism basically calling for genocide
you can't they literally call it out for
genocide you know they're doing that
they are literally racist not only that
they go and rip off um Palestinian Flags
across uh the country and then
afterwards they start attacking Muslim
Moroccans yes now Moroccans you don't
want to mess with them Tajin kuskus my
friend listen anyone that has Tajin and
Kos you don't want to mess with them and
the Moroccans did exactly that they said
you're going to come to city after what
you've been doing and you will see very
clearly that when they were retaliating
now to this you're going to come here do
you think this is Israel bro they think
they are under this delusion of we are
God's chosen people they think they're
Untouchable bro come and try that bro
come and try that you going and massing
kids are dare you to come and try that
here man dare you man you know so the
thing is you can see after that then the
Moroccans and I won't be there was non
Muslims there who went there and you
know retaliated and anyone in the far
right or anyone for that matter
if the Muslims was was to do this was to
go and chant Isis slogans the far right
if they came together yeah the Tommy the
dirt bag who's in prison now if he came
on the streets and they came to defend
the country you know they're ripping out
British flags enchanting um supporting
Isis whatever for that matter and they
went out there and attacked these people
nobody would bat an eye nobody so the
matter of the context is that and then
this happened and then they found out
that some of the actual EXC IDF soldiers
one of them was screaming like a baby
like this I well I'll be honest with
what humiliation embarrassment yes and
then one of them jumped in the river yes
so the thing that these were saying was
oh do you think you're going to do this
for kids you're you're killing kids
you're killing kids come and try that
here come try that here so you can see
the the the motivation behind it was the
massacre that was carrying out in J it
had nothing to do with them being jued I
did not hear any of those videos oh
you're a Jew this you're a Jew that or
this that it's got nothing to do with
anti-Semitism you come to a country you
do this and that's why these footages
that you saw is what evident to show you
what actually happened and these people
are absolutely cowards like Allah says
in the Quran they will not fight you
unless they are in fortified c a WS
that's the thing whenever they are
confronted by real men one to one combat
whatever it is for that matter either
they're crying either they're running
either they're one of them saying Oh I
will give you money money leave me alone
I mean just they just because the desist
think everything works with money it
doesn't doesn't work you some people
they have more morals than you they have
more principles money is not going to
work all going to say money you get it
and again I'm not trying to condone
violence anyway she perform I'm against
that but the point I'm saying is that
you cannot expect to go to a specific
community and do bizarre weird things
like that which is pro genocide racism
islamophobia and so many other things
rip up Flags try to attack cab drivers
and then be surprised when the community
retaliates nobody will see this as you
know what yes of course they should
leave it to the law but what I'm saying
is if you have people you cannot control
people you cannot be surprised so you
can see what exactly happened when the
idea of confronted by Moroccans whove
had extra custos and T on the day it's a
bit Peak I wouldn't mess with them I
mean and the Moroccans show theirselfs
hope you guys enjoyed the video and once
again I told you guys as I would like to
say you know I condemn this Behavior
hope you guys enjoy yourself